[Music]
orchestras come in all shapes and sizes
if you're open to playing around
there's no limit to how
where or what kind of music you make so
sit back and tune in to these ensembles
that are anything but typical
[Music]
my name is alex holman and i play tenor
smith corona with the boston typewriter
orchestra the boston typewriter
orchestra is an ensemble for typewriter
and voice some of us have musical
backgrounds some of us don't several of
our members play in bands currently i
haven't touched much of anything except
for a typewriter since playing the
trombone in high school we play a wide
variety of typewriters from some small
portable models all the way up to some
relatively large desk models
[Music]
a lot of what we do in building up songs
is really exploring what different
sounds we can get out of the typewriter
and how we can incorporate them into a
song
for example you have the the key makes
sort of
a basic clack sound
but then you have the the shift that
moves a lot of the mechanics and makes
somewhat of a bass sound then you also
have the the roller that gets a uh
get sort of a mechanical ratchet sound
to it um and then all of them we can
work with the uh
the carriage return for like the
you know the standard swoopy sound to it
as our name suggests the boston
typewriter orchestra is boston based but
we've actually played all over new
england
most of the typewriters are 50 60 70
years old
usually in our hands we see two to three
years of lifespan we feed on them pretty
hard
my fingers have hurt when we started out
in 2004 we were we were a bunch of guys
getting together and kind of banging on
typewriters we get that we're kind of
weird it's a little bit of a wacky idea
but we've discovered that this makes
some legitimate music and it can be a
real serious endeavor we have true songs
that come together and people seem to
really enjoy them and as long as we
still are entertaining people we're
gonna stay out there typing
[Music]
very often people think it's gonna be
funny and then they realize it's not
really we really do music
it's not impossible to make music with
vegetables
[Music]
my name is susanna gardmeyer and then
i'm a member of the vegetable orchestra
the orchestra exists since 18 years now
the first instrument was the tomato
because you can
do sound with tomatoes but it will be
messy for sure
we go shopping on the market first we
choose all the vegetables there
we have three kinds of instruments
one is the ready-made you can just buy
it at the market and play it it's like
the
pepper it's called no
[Music]
it's ready already
and then they're just simple instruments
like with
one cut or some cuts
you get it like that then with the more
complex instruments we have some that
work like normal instruments you know
the pumpkin is the bass drum and the
sound of the pumpkin is really important
good
after shopping we go to the venue and
start to build instruments
all in all it takes two to three hours
to build all the instruments for
everybody
and then we start with the sound check
and since we have new instruments each
time
we have to have a very long sound check
[Applause]
we have a lot of
different musical influences
in the orchestra since really many
people everybody is interested in
different things
we make a soup during the building
process of the vegetable instruments
with the remaining vegetables and we
serve it to the audience after the
concert
and it's also after hearing and seeing
us and smelling the vegetables which
will be intense in there because it's so
small this theater and then you can also
eat it
you never get it out of your head
anymore if you're in the orchestra to
look vegetables in another way
walking down this quiet street in
brooklyn
you'd never know that inside this
building within this tiny apartment
music is made
meet evan
and luke they're long-time friends and
roommates evan and i have been living
together here for
how many years have we landed the other
man about a year and a half year and a
half
and once a month in only about 500
square feet they managed to pile in up
to 60 musicians for the ultimate
recording session i think we should put
five or six people in the bathroom
[Music]
for each arrangement we record it in
about three hours and post it online
[Music]
a lot of people's reactions are that it
seems crazy and it is crazy to pull this
off first they have to uproot their
humble abode anything that is not
involved in making music has to go
we take all the furniture out we take
most of the doors off it's just all
about making as much room and as much
sight lines as possible it really just
looks like chaos there's mic stands
everywhere the floor is littered with
music stands
i'm a little worried about this though
there's not a single inch to spare and
that's because they make way for the
strings woodwinds
horns
percussion and a full chorus
yeah that's a marimba in the kitchen but
why i wanted an opportunity to record a
bunch of people at the same time
luke wanted an opportunity to hear his
arrangements played and so we just
invited a bunch of people over and
although it seems unconventional there's
a reason for the madness we're trying to
change the way that you might see an
orchestra play there is a special
dynamic and a feeling in the room that
you won't get in a recording studio or
in a public venue
it's this unique sound and sense of
community that has attracted musicians
from all over the country to participate
there's definitely something really
exciting about the idea that this
shouldn't really be possible it's a
really unique experience and i think
that people are drawn to that and so
they keep at it
[Music]
it's a real
kind of jarring wonderful experience
every time and we love it and i bet the
neighbors must love it too they're lucky
they're good
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
an ice instrument has the purity and the
clarity of the heavenly realm
it's not of the earth in the way that a
wooden instrument would be
there's so much potential in ice as an
acoustic material
[Music]
my name is tim linhart and i am the
founder of ice music
ice music is the music that we make on
this orchestra of ice instruments
the idea first came to me about 21 years
ago i was an ice sculptor for many years
decided one of my sculptures i'd like to
build a giant violin and i had a friend
who was building guitars and he just
asked the question yeah i wonder how
that one's going to sound and that
question has swallowed much of the rest
of my life
[Music]
the instruments are made of white ice
which is a mixture of snow and water
it's filled with snowflakes and air
bubbles and all kind of different things
going on
to make a single instrument a violin or
viola here the ice part takes about five
or six days i can probably build the
whole orchestra here in about seven or
eight weeks we have violins violas
cellos bass
guitars mandolins banjos drums and
xylophone
[Music]
ice music is not just classical music or
experimental music it's a wide variety
of different things
this winter we'll put on about 45
concerts the concert hall has a specific
design it's one giant ice cave
the igloo right now is 10 degrees
fahrenheit it's definitely an issue in
ice music that people's fingers get cold
people play with a variety of different
kinds of gloves some people play
barehanded but for me the temperature is
you know the thing that i really need to
make ice music work
[Applause]
so many people just cannot wrap their
brain around a piece of ice making a
sound or a beautiful sound
when they come into the ice concert hall
and they're just very very pleasantly
surprised and that releases a real kind
of a high for people and then wow it's
it's amazing
[Music]
you